>> my name is Jane Chueh, and I'm a clinical professor at the Stanford
Medical School, Medical Center. Clinically, I work
as a high-risk obstetrician which means we see
high-risk pregnancies. And I also do fetal
ultrasounds on pregnancies in general, looking for fetal
anomalies. So, every patient that we see we do require that we know their blood
type and Rh type. And I know you talked
a lot about the A, B, O blood system. It's
important because at delivery there's a chance that they may
bleed whether they have a vaginal delivery or whether they
have a c-section. sometimes they bleed. Most of the time
they bleed very minimally, so they don't require transfusion, but
occasionally, in rare cases, they have a lot of bleeding.
and it becomes a very complicated case where they require,um
lots of blood. if you need blood, then it's important to have the type of blood
that the person receives matched to their type.
So we, we want to know what that is.
And in fact we actually require they be
typed twice. So they're typed at a prenatal
visit, and they're also typed when they come
in before they receive blood. So there's two that
>> It's that important?
>> Th-, that is important. ' Cause you can't just could, it could be
a mistake. I mean the, one, if they have just one result. So the,
the policy is that there's two that actually correlate. That, that
they're the same. if you don't have a blood type then,
and you need blood, then the only option is, you know,
the blood bank gives you universal donor, which would be O negative.
but O negative is not the most common type of blood
there is and, you know, you can't use up your entire
pool of O negative blood. So the best thing would be
to you know, give the person the type of blood that they
actually have. So in pregnancy particularly the
RH factor which is a rhesus blood group
on the red cell is, is important this refers to a group of antigens, the most
common being the D antigen. And there's a D positive group and there's a D
negative antigen you know, where they, they're missing
the D antigen. So everybody has two alleles,
right, so there, they could be D positive D positive,
or D positive D negative, or D negative D negative.
>> So it's kind of like the O type where
O is nothing whereas you have A, B or nothing.
>> Correct, exactly. Exactly. So, just like with
A blood type, you can have homozygous A, which'd
be A positive, A positive, or heterozygous A which
would be A plus O. A plus O, right,
where A, O. And so, this becomes an issue when we find an
rh negative. Woman who's neg, D negative, D negative. so if she
marries a partner who is not RH negative,
in other words, he's RH positive and he's
either D plus D plus or D plus D negative. Both of them are which are considered
you know, D or RH positive. then there's a chance that her child could be RH
positive. Either D plus, well actually would have
to be a 100% D plus D negative right?
>> Right.
>> Because one of the genes comes from her and will be D negative.
And the other is going to come from her partner. So, we need to
know what her partner's genotype is for the RH antigen. And we need
to know if the fetus has you know, a 100% chance of being RH positive.
>> And so just to be clear here than, the risk here
is that the mother would be RH negative and the baby is
RH positive
>> Correct.
>> And if the mother's and the baby's blood were to see each other, that the
mothers blood might not recognize the RH positive
in the baby blood and attack it or something?
>> Bas, no, basically, if the mother is RH negative and sees the RH
positive in the fetus' blood, fetal blood,
then it will recognize it as being foreign.
>> I see
>> Cause she's never seen the, the Antigen until she became pregnant.
>> So what are, besides the
actual mother, mother-fetus interaction, are
there any other important clinical settings
related to this or otherwise, where knowing blood type's really important?
>> just the first one. You know, for, for the mother, mostly for her--
>> Mostly for the mother.
>> --her safety and if she hemorrhaged during preg,
during pregnancy or delivery, that she would need blood. So.
>> And, and there are times when, I guess, patients need
a lot of blood, or a little bit of blood, I mean--
>> Lots.
>> --is there ever, has there ever been a scenario
where you're like, oh, gosh, I need this type
of blood, but, you know, I don't have enough, or?
>> Yes.
>> What do you do?
>> So yeah we have something called massive transfusion protocol. this happens
when there's an,obstetrical hemorrhage disaster that
happens. usually if you have time you
try to give matched blood. And you know the persons blood type.
especially if you anticipate the possibility
and she's already been crossed and matched.
but, if not, you know, you, you activate the protocol
and you give O- blood. And, and we've had cases
where, due to certain conditions of the placenta and the
uterus. Especially one called the placenta accreta, where the placenta grows
into the uterus. Where you can't remove the placenta. After
delivery we have to remove the entire uterus. And there's
so much blood flow that they, the mothers lose so
much blood they can receive, you know, 50 to 100 units
of blood. So, for all the sort of
the general origin native women, they receive something called
rhogam during pregnancy. Rhogam is an immune globulin that
blocks, the antigens on the red cells. So if
you might imagine the fetal cell trying to get
into the maternal circulation if we got in there,
the rhogam would just attached itself to all the
sites bind all the sites so the mother can't
see the antigens.
>> That's clever.
>> And you can't, she won't, she want
amount of response So, that way, if the fetus
happened to be RH positive, RH positive, that's
correct, then she won't see the positive D antigen.